the number of men reporting notes in the
last year has tripled from 8 to 28 from
2008 to 2018. roll that clock forward
the next four years through the pandemic
I honestly think if you see a man on the
street between the ages of 18 and 30 he
pointed at him there would be a 50
chance that he hasn't had sex in the
last year when you get into a
relationship as a man your testosterone
drops when you have children you
testosterone drops again what this means
is it reduces risk-taking Behavior
amongst men and this would make sense
like if you now have to provide for
first a wife and then kids don't try and
jump off that cliff and say if you don't
die right because if you leave behind
some kids that aren't going to be able
to fend for themselves that's not good
for your genetic line right if you don't
have many married men and or men with
kids you have a greater increase in
risk-taking behavior and testosterone
the problem that you have at the moment
is we have the highest rates of
sexlessness amongst young men I think
ever in history that's not good